hello rejects Greg here no we're gonna
watch from top training a friend the
real rejects ten actors actors who
actually did it on screen this is all
taken from pornos Melissa Roz I only
have ten but whatever the vast majority
of films rely on body doubles and
camerawork to accomplish the illusion of
actual sex act yes however there are a
handful of movies that smoking mirrors
entirely these movies are the maniac sex
scenes between their actors some of them
are extremely explicit and others more
subtle the 2005 movie lie with me is
particularly notable in part because of
the two main stars Erik Balto and Lauren
Lee Smith are fairly well known
particularly backer the to engage in
extremely graphic and also extremely
real sex likes on the novel by tomorrow
burger the film follows a man and a
woman around the City of Toronto as they
initiate an intense affair with each
other
Lauren Lise hits characters portrayed as
a sex addict and is therefore the main
subject for most of the adult material
some of the scenes include Lee Smith's
character having multiple masturbation
sessions Wow which took place in a
public park
Smith fellating buffer for taking in
public sex and even sodomy the film's
release was unsurprisingly met with
mostly negative reviews and now it
resides with a fairly dismal rating of
38 percent on Rotten Tomatoes oh boy a
list actor Chloe Sevigny me before we
continue it's just kind of sad when an
actor goes all out like that you know
like I'm gonna really commit to this
role I'm gonna do all these really
revealing sexual scenes and then people
don't like the movie oh man what I
didn't really know those two actors that
one guys look kind of familiar but I
can't really tell you what he's from I
think either effeminate did Chloe Savini
mistake have agreed to play the love
interest in the movie the brown bunny a
mistake that would haunt her in
career for many years to come on its
release at the 2003 Cannes Film Festival
the brown bunny an arthouse independent
film about a lonely motorcycle driver on
a cross-country tour left audience is
shot appalled and disgusted all because
of a single 4-minute event which took
place in the movie rarely has the
controversy over a single scene eclipsed
the whole movie is totally and as
completely like the on screen [ __ ] in
the brown bunny did occurring late in
the film the scene in question had Chloe
Sevigny performing unstimulated fellatio
on Vincent Gallo's character to the
point of completion up to make matters
more to surrogate Vincent Gallo who
played believable also wrote and
directed the film as well as personally
contacting Sevigny about playing his
characters counterpart later during a
post release interview he stated that
for months leading up to the making of
the movie he had obsessed with Chloe
Sevigny and had wrote her character
specifically for her to play he hinted
that if she refused the role he wouldn't
have moved forward with the film almost
as if he had ulterior motives over ten
years later diggie has been able to
recover from the blow her acting career
shape from his American niveau no oh
that's horrible yes that was a good pun
though that's crazy yeah was it I don't
get how she walked how you get someone
to agree to do that some people will do
anything for like rule yeah for all
that's like it's one of the stills they
showed it I've never heard of that movie
but the stills they showed of it were
like that see it and he finishes that's
crazy
for the round he's an American Horror
Story season 5 is she yeah she's one of
the main characters oh oh she's doing
fine yeah
no one knows I didn't know we're gonna
bring it back up on the internet though
we're gonna remind everyone well that's
your choice a manipulative director true
he really did have ulterior motives as
top-trending says years later Sevigny
has been able to recover from the blow
her acting career took from the
controversy
director Lars von Trier has become quite
well-known for pushing the envelope in
mainstream movies by choosing to unseal
8 sec scenes so pardon with actor Shia
LaBeouf is surely guaranteed to produce
something controversial especially
considering actor Shia LaBeouf is also
no stranger to pushing the envelope for
the cameras
he had already risked it all by exposing
himself in a music video for artists
sigur rós but he took himself a step
further when he started nymphomaniac
alongside stacy martin taking on
possibly his most mature role yet Shia
LaBeouf has confirmed that in the Flake
nothing was off-limits
including the scripts real sex scenes
the film nymphomaniac follows the story
of a young self-diagnosed
modest sex played by stacy martin as she
recounts her staggering amount of erotic
experiences to an older man who just
found her beaten unconscious in an
alleyway many of those erotic
experiences recurrently featured Shia
LaBeouf recently however stacy martin
had stated in an interview that while
the sex is real LaBeouf and her never
actually consummated their contracts she
alleges that any in all real acts were
performed by pornography actors with
their faces overlaid onto the porn stars
which directly contrast claims
previously made by Shia LaBeouf in Lars
von Trier in multiple different
interviews since Martin's reveal the two
of again stepped forward to reinstate
that the fornication scene on screen was
in fact nothing less than authentic
which begs the question who's telling
the truth what the hell is going on with
that movie that's food it's a weird
situation yeah just so you know for this
movie we had the actors have real sex
actress comes out no they've had
pornographic actors and they put faces
on it then the actors come out of the
light no gods
we need to reassure you this was a real
sexy this is vital to your experience of
the movie i watch you know we really had
sex
I believe Shia clearly he's the most
sane level-headed one of them all I
always tell saya always tells the truth
always never loses it still love
watching I love is I never gets okay
whoa Shia LaBeouf's having sex crazy we
gave him a ring lover I think you know
he did that scene with SIA then he had a
real sexy nymphomania now he needs to do
a gay sex scene for real
we should head up James Franco we should
hit up James Franco it was Argentinian
filmmaker gasp oh no A's first film
after a five-year hiatus there is a plot
to love but that's secondary to the sex
gasp oh no age love story is relentless
Oh Oh explodes how many times are in
there been ever so popular glorious 3d
you could call it porn if you like but
you can't deny that the acting and story
are exponentially better the erotic
drama about a film school student named
Murphy played by Karl bluesman and his
ex-girlfriend Electra who is captured by
all mean walk the twos relationship
comes to a tragic end when Murphy
commits infidelity with a girl Nate
oming played by Clara Christin that
resulted in her getting pregnant half
the film takes place in bed with
unblinking and unforgiving extended
takes of bluesman Luke and Kristen
making love to each other the director
gets up close and personal in order to
express the deeper mysteries of
relationships but the message was
ultimately lost the director faced a lot
of criticism namely because his previous
films had received such high acclaim
people had high hopes that he would
break boundaries and redefine acting in
cinema with love yet somehow against all
odds having called bluesman Zi Jack Y
elated semen 3d jump off the screen and
toward the audience members didn't
change the cinema industry as we know it
I guess love's just tricky bad way
unwittingly tick Wow
there was a 3d movie out there like that
ha ha ha get out of your face there's
like no point for that well yes if you
wanted to feel like you're actually
there for the sex sounds like a scary
situation have you ever been in like
involved in like any kind of like
three-person scenario no me neither
I know shocking right people see me all
the time they think wow he's probably
been with at least seven women at one
time not me though
not me I'm no trump until then
I don't even know if I could really do a
scene like that like could you even do a
scene with like another girl and another
guy and you got like it was like
simulating sex no probably not right
mm-hmm
I like comedy like a good eg 13 comedy
yeah
unwittingly taking method acting to a
whole new level
the Twilight Fame dr. Robert Pattinson
has recently opened up about explicit
male-only sex scenes in the Spanish I
need to bring my image in which you
started Salvador Dali the film directed
by our paths focuses on Dolly's love
affair with the esteemed poet Federico
Garcia Lorca played by Javier Beltran
caddis enclaved the director árpád's who
is known to be a stickler for perfection
absolutely refused to settle for
anything that he didn't feel was
authentic enough which stirred up
tensions between the two when filming
the climax of the movie the scene called
for Pattinson character to pleasure
himself thoroughly until he too had whom
climaxed árpád's was continually
dissatisfied with canons performance
with each tank he would demand another
reshoot after multiple reshoots
Pattinson finally caved and begrudgingly
agreed to take the final step to help
capture a truly authentic experience
I'll be an embarrassed
Pattinson fully committed to doing a
take of him actually masturbating on
camera just to add in so far got four
guys it's fine a bit just to add insult
to an injured bride the a-list celeb
went on to add we were all hanging out
by the pool trying to loosen up I was
nervously clinging to the edge and
before I could turn around Javier
Beltran was already naked he happily
swam toward me route continued about the
gay sex scene and I didn't have a clue
how to react
I felt like mr. bean no doubt that
filming sex scenes has to be awkward for
movie stars but it's unlikely that a
majority of them have had to do the
dirty deed in front of the full camera
crew and a new drum adult heinessen said
that the whole ordeal was so
traumatizing he had promised himself
he'd quit acting if the movie was
complete however he didn't stay true to
his promise as a few days later he was
offered what ultimately proved to be his
career making role as Edward Cullen in
the Twilight series
if you happen to be looking for a movie
that is so discomforting it'll did that
move you ever get me yeah came out can i
after twilit oh just two great movies
sound like pretty abusive situations
yeah that sounds terrible I'm not gay
though I feel like if I was doing a role
would just feel like a role I do it well
not saying that being gay is terrible I
mean doing that's exactly what I heard
yeah doing something that you're
uncomfortable with but like being forced
to do it on camera especially for a guy
to have to like work up an erection
yeah weird that must feel like I'm
uncomfortable getting erection by myself
we do men know this girl especially uh
monkey though - comes like that yeah you
know again you know you're getting
pressure moving a whole image of you and
really got a weird me out look no
further the movie dog soup is the film
for you oh by Georgia and Deimos this
film features some brief but very real
adult encounters the ki helps into the
taboo topic of incest as it tells the
story of a girl's dysfunctional
upbringing that is a direct result of
her father's forced reclusion the
children are forced to stay on their
family's property being shielded from
the outside world and all the bad
influences it offers as the father
describes it the critically acclaimed
film circles around the perverse
storyline of the three teenage siblings
as their dysfunctional lifestyle spirals
them into isolated mandates being played
by Angela kipapa Leah bestows Posadas
and Mary Sun the unseen you Layton
scenes cut to the core and truly display
the type of unhealthy mindset that can
develop from isolation and lack of
control over one's body and life ranging
from the two girls Angelica Papa Leah
and Mary son using oral sex as a
bartering system for items from the
outside world to the parents forcing the
brother bestows Posadas to choose which
sibling he prefer as a sexual partner
the film hits the nail on the head with
making you feel uneasy
would you assess Cory that's that's that
makes me uncomfortable
incest yeah why does you having a
brother
well sure let's get more specific
because you have a an attractive brother
why did that come to your mind oh I
could see it being tempting is all know
I know relate I'm trying to understand
I'm not trying to trying to be a good
person right now monnet trying to make
you I feel comfortable hey man back then
like hundreds of years ago people bone
their sisters and brothers all the time
I don't
I have a brother incident we're done
we're moving on yeah thank you doing the
deed on camera if it turned out that it
was so atrocious to watch that it ended
up on nerves list of the 50 worst sex
scenes of all time while for curing O
Brien and Margo stilly they saw no shame
in openly admitting to doing the deed on
the set of the 2004 movie nine songs the
feature film is about a relationship
between a college to give me an abrasion
on his finger not get played by stilling
who for the following months after
meeting at a rock concert having 10
sexual encounters the movie also
includes real concert footage of The
Dandy Warhols Black Rebel Motorcycle
Club Franz Ferdinand and many other acts
forbidden night songs is the most
sexually explicit mainstream movie ever
released lettering there are multiple
unsimilar sex acts between the two leads
it isn't all that surprising
unfortunately most critics uniformly
disliked it with audiences opinions
following soon most considered the film
pretentious and boring Mona knows about
most of these films it's a porn with a
good story no that's the problem it's
their porn with a bad story with a lot
of intentions to make a good movie ah
you know like a lot of these movies
turned out like they're all right or
these are bad but they're very explicit
sexy yeah I should say a better story
than in porn well it depends what porno
you're watching I think anything with
actually I can't think of any porn stars
names right now the Devil Wears nada not
a real thing
cleavage feel he's real yeah yeah when I
was looking I like my directv lists they
came up there's another one oh you
really want to tell the world to watch
porn I didn't watch it it was under lit
on the list on your specific heuu list
come on nowadays for playing the role of
man's happiness President Snow in The
Hunger Games Donald Sutherland has had
the good fortune to play many iconic
characters throughout his long acting
career she has playing Hawkeye and mash
John Bridger in the Italian Job and of
course John Baxter in the 1973 movie
don't look now for many years rumours
had spread that Sutherland and female
lead Julie Christie were actually
intimate during the shooting of Don't
Look Now for an unknown reason any and
all attempts to get a direct answer from
anyone involved on the movie are refused
it wasn't until 38 years later in 2011
when news editor Brian Clark finally
revealed the truth and confirmed what
everyone had already suspected Oh
starring aging acting Ike hey Donald
Sutherland keeper Sutherlands dead
really yeah Donald Sutherland in a sex
scene you got my money I'm talking now
current day
post Hunger Games Donald Sutherland Oh
if they're willing to do a sex scene
with a man that old you got to pay to
watch it this videos getting weird
it's not weird I'm just talking about
like dude that guy he clearly has gotten
wants a ball he has courage you know
he's got to pay that respect and be like
[ __ ] I'll watch her movie then not out
of like a sexual thing but as a way to
go man thar be 97 years old and doing a
sex scene to break your head I don't
want to picture it well you are now a
Last Tango in Paris
Marlon Brando then aged 48 and exuding
aggressive masculinity and Maria
Schneider and I'm known that
French enter Last Tango in Paris
released in 1972 was undoubtedly one of
the most influential and controversial
films ever created in the last century
featuring one of the most infamous movie
sex scenes ever filmed the movie upon
release was denounced for being too
obscene and found itself being steadily
banned in a growing handful of countries
including many areas of Britain the film
a tale of lust between an older man and
younger woman who meet for anonymous and
increasingly racy sexual encounters gain
unexpected worldwide attention due to
the controversy which for Mariah
Schneider proved to be too much for her
to handle causing her to embark in a
path of self-destruction with fraught
romantic entanglements suicide attempts
and a lapse into drug addiction
eventually falling back into obscurity
however thirty five years later after
the passing of marlon brando she
returned to finally put a rest to the
question everyone had been asking where
the adult scenes real or face she
admitted that the scenes were authentic
but added that she believes she and
Brando were heavily manipulated by the
director Bernardo Bertolucci into
performing the act
sadly Schneider later stated in the same
interview I felt humiliated and to be
honest I felt a little weight both by
Marlon and by Bertolucci after the scene
Marlon didn't consoled me or apologized
thankfully there was just one page
before playing any oh that's horrible
that's terrible Marlon Brando I think he
was a he was pretty sexual guy I read
one of his books and that's like all he
talked about why you got a crazy life
ma'am crazy upbringing did he have like
two kids that died two did he think hey
I want you to kill himself oh that's
terrible I can another kid what's jail
like it wasn't the healthiest guy great
actor but damn I feel like on a movie
now that probably wouldn't happen but I
feel like for film back then it was
probably much easier to like manipulate
an actress into doing stuff I hope that
does not happen I hope people stand up
for themselves do not put up with that
[ __ ] you're worried I'm worried a woman
might do it to me
seeing this mm-hmm this is be nice
people
ladies be nice to me everyone I only get
erections when I'm terrified sorry
good okay I'm pressured to do it real
fast we're about to talk about this
actor Peter Sarsgaard there's any actor
I've ever just commonly have said over
the years so I just can't stand it's
this sleepy I [ __ ] he is always
so sleepy has like no emotion ever I
like him in this movie though jarhead
but other than that I just don't really
like the sacrum and Kathy really gets on
my nerves breakout roles such as Alan
Trillian jarhead and Hector Hammond and
Green Lantern Peter Sarsgaard played a
lead role in the center of the world
alongside Molly Parker most notable for
her portrayal of minor characters in the
road and house of cards publicly
released in 2001 the film's story
revolves around the life of a depressed
computer wiz on the verge of becoming a
dot-com millionaire who offers a lap
dancer at a club ten thousand dollars to
spend three nights with him in Vegas hi
so the conditions of four hours max per
night of erotic grind is no winner
Kirk's can recover yeah sorry last time
the movie became most infamously known
for a scene in which Molly Parker
inserts a lollipop into herself and no
it did not end up in her mouth in
addition to the lollipop scene parker
performs many suggestive acts on peter
sarsgaard including but not limited to
coitus what is coitus any real story and
primarily being an adult content critics
blasted the film giving awful ratings
and describing the movie is nothing more
than a high budget pornography luckily
peter sarsgaard was able to bounce back
just in time to get a major role in the
equally as disliked movie the Green
Lantern equally just like oh god
alright guys subscribe to top trending
don't watch any Peter Sarsgaard movies
was coitus means sexual intercourse I've
never heard that before in my life
but i'ma start using it I'm gonna sorry
using it to a casual conversation some
coitus with me Hani
Queen I'm a brain around people who I
know are gonna be too afraid to just act
like they don't know what to do
like they know what the word oh yeah
yeah yeah courtesan I got chorusing all
the time
been there done that what you see in
France the other day last night boy did
you caught us at the margin my boy did
yeah yeah who doesn't coitus up the
market right my kids going to set the
board wow-whee we got through it all Mon
Adam ate it we got through it all wow
there's are those are some crazy stuff
so here's what we learned if a director
on a low-budget film is pressuring you
into doing sex scenes oh yes
coitus coitus scenes real non simulation
coitus scenes you probably shouldn't do
it cuz it's probably gonna be a [ __ ]
movie or you're gonna be that one woman
from Last Tango in Paris
who's gonna not look great down the road
because she's gonna be miserable for the
next 30 years waiting for the star and
the director to die so she can finally
talk about it have the strength to
respect yourself exactly not risking on
one film because it ain't worth yeah you
got to be tough you gotta be tough like
a black girl do you see any black girls
in this video what I'm saying white
women are weak black girls that's where
it's at you won't see a black girl get
in position like this in a film don't
yawn don't you high enough copy today
taking a stand for black women trying to
show their empowerment you know I don't
think you get in a situation like this
whenever probably just think it's a joke
they'll probably laugh and be like ah
good one good one oh you're serious
I'm out of here guys are crazy
you oughta boot that lollipop
subscribers are trending describe the
real rejects Monette Moliere is on sweet
Oh YouTube channel her host Coast Jessie
Luca toured oh yes see they cook bake
healthy foods in a delicious way you
will enjoy their videos I've been in a
couple videos I opted to be in them
weekly I've said they're not necessary
just put me in it I don't know why they
just one let me take over the channel
you have to politely harest I mean I
don't know how to bake but I can react
to baking videos [ __ ]
that's what sweetie channels would be if
I was in charge
yeah me reacting to the older videos of
sweetie I take over the ship